[Musique]
l'invité politique c'est Jean-Louis
bourlange qui est député Renaissance et
Président
vous êtes Modène absolument vous êtes
député MoDem et président de la
commission ensemble absolument tout à
fait vous êtes président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'Assemblée nationale monsieur bourlange
merci d'être là sur ce plateau
est-ce qu'il vous semble que ce qui se
passe en mer de Chine méridionale et
juste un épisode de plus dans le bras de
fer entre l'Amérique et la Chine et
Taïwan au milieu qui dure depuis des
dizaines d'années où c'est plus grave
que ça donc c'est un épisode de plus
mais c'est une sur une escalade sur une
aggravation constante et là évidemment
une étape importante a été franchie
parce que l'investissement
l'investissement militaire de l'île de
Taïwan par la République populaire de
Chine n'a jamais été aussi agressif
donc nous sommes vraiment à la limite à
la limite de
d'une épreuve armée et donc je crois que
c'est à quelque chose c'est une
situation à très très haut risque et
très très préoccupant on a une une
population taïwanaise qui n'est pas
n'est pas un de constitue pas un État
indépendant mais dont nous pensons les
uns et les autres qu'elle doit continuer
à vivre librement avec son modèle
politique économique et social et dont
l'existence et dont la liberté même est
très très sévèrement mise en cause sur
un fond stratégique et c'est ça qui est
très important d'incertitude parce qu'on
ne sait pas du tout jusqu'où les
Américains s'estiment prêt à aller en
cas de confrontation et cette
incertitude est en soi un facteur
d'insécurité important monsieur
bourlange c'est totalement hors de la
zone d'influence géopolitique de la
France là-bas c'est clair donc nous à
notre petite échelle on est quand même
pas des nains diplomatiques et ce qu'on
peut faire quelque chose pour calmer le
jeu ou pas ce qu'on peut on peut tout à
fait concourir je crois pas que nous
ayons sur cette sur cette affaire la
possibilité d'avoir une attitude
différente de celle des États-Unis il
est évidente l'enjeu militaire c'est un
enjeu entre la Chine et les États-Unis
avec cette incertitude sur le deuil que
j'évoquais sur le degré d'implication
des États-Unis et nous moi je je suis
très profondément solidaire de du combat
de la population taïwanaise pour rester
libre et je trouve qu'on doit manifester
notre solidarité mais s'il est évident
que on est très directement concerné par
la guerre en Ukraine mais que sur le
plan de Taïwan c'est pas les
gesticulations militaires que nous
pourrions faire qui serait décisive donc
la question est-ce que nous devons sur
ce nous séparer des États-Unis je crois
pas je crois que nous avons le souci
peut-être un peu plus que les États-Unis
de garder des relations de travail et de
coopération avec la Chine populaire mais
sur cette affaire quand les affaires
deviennent vraiment sérieux je pense que
les défenseurs des démocraties doivent
être solidaires vous avez noté monsieur
bourlange que Jean-Luc Mélenchon s'est
fendu d'un tweet en l'occurrence je
crois ou me semble-t-il très tôt ce
matin en disant qu'il était totalement
solidaire de l'action des Chinois face à
Taiwan oui vous savez il y avait déjà il
avait déjà été solidaire de l'action des
chinois au Tibet au nom de la défense de
la laïcité depuis il a mis l'eau dans
son vin en matière de laïcité mais les
Tibétains ont quand même apprécié que la
la mammise
d'alchine sur le Tibet se soit une
atteinte une défense de la laïcité une
question je vous en prie
sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon il disait aussi
précisément qu'il y avait eu une
provocation des États-Unis à travers la
visite madame Pelosi hathawan qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez au-delà de votre
analyse structurelle
Maison Blanche dans la situation madame
Pelosi si j'ai je ne sais pas si
j'aurais fait ce voyage mais ce que je
sais c'est qu'on ne peut pas considérer
que la visite d'une personnalité
politique
est un pays ami dans son lit de Taïwan
soit considéré comme un acte éminemment
dangereux genre map d'ailleurs que le
président de la Chambre des représentant
monsieur konich avait été déjà venu à
Taïwan je crois à la fin du siècle
dernier en 97 et ça n'avait pas du tout
ça n'avait pas du tout provoqué les les
réactions que ça provoque on voit bien
et le l'ambassadeur de Chine à Paris qui
a un grand mérite c'est celui de dire
très clairement ce que son gouvernement
pense monsieur louchaillé a dit
clairement que il vous voulez reprendre
en masse population taïwanaise et lui
faire subir une rééducation ce qui quand
on voit ce qui se passe à Hong Kong ou
ailleurs et quand même assez préoccupant
non je pense qu'un population libre que
des autorités libres ont le droit
d'accueillir sur leur territoire les
amis de leur choix
n'est pas arrivé avec des missiles dans
sa poche monsieur bourlange vous avez
noté comme nous tous le changement de
ton du président de la République
vis-à-vis de Monsieur Poutine puisque
lors de sa visite en Afrique de l'Ouest
il l'a attaqué très directement il
semblerait que la diplomatie avec les
Russes soient derrière nous qu'on a plus
rien à négocier avec les Russes dans le
contexte de la guerre en Ukraine vous
comprenez ce virement de bord vous
l'approuvez moi je crois que le
président a fait tous ces tous les
efforts possibles avant le déclenchement
de la guerre avant le 24 février puis
après le 24 février pour essayer de
d'amener le président
à revenir sur une action qui est
insensée sur le plan géopolitique est
absolument indépendable sur le plan des
principes des valeurs du droit etc qui
constate que ces efforts sont
actuellement 20 je dirais que pour
l'instant effectivement le l'urgence
c'est d'aider les Ukrainiens à résister
de leur donner les moyens de faire face
à une offensive d'une brutalité inouïe
car je rappelle que la technique la
stratégie offensive des Russes elle est
abominable ça consiste c'est la fameuse
phrase du Maréchal Foch sur la guerre de
14 l'artillerie conquiert et
l'infanterie occupe ce qui veut dire
l'artillerie détruit tout et ensuite sur
un désert on occupe bon et là le
président est quand même très et
confronté à cette réalité et il ne peut
pas la
dissimulée mais ce que nous savons tous
c'est qu'à la fin des fins il faudra
dans des conditions qui seront fixées
par nos amis Ukrainiens il faudra bien
comme dirait Napoléon avec les Vendéens
faudra bien causer
vous emprisez
l'Europe ne risque pas d'être confronté
à un nouveau foyer de guerre sur son
propre territoire avec la Serbie ce qui
se passe entre la Serbie et la Croatie
est-ce que ce n'est pas un terrain
supplémentaire de de d'offensive et
d'extensions en tout cas d'un pouvoir
politique de la Russie dans cette région
je ne dirais pas comme Winston Churchill
que la les Balkans d'une capacité de
nuisance supérieure à leur poids
démographique je me garderai bien de
dire une phrase vous pourriez nos amis
balkaniques mais je crois qu'il faut
faire très très attention à tout ça
cela dit je pense que les Russes ont
quand même assez sur le
sur
le dos avec cette agression dont il
n'arrive pas qui n'arrive pas à gérer de
façon satisfaisante en Ukraine bon cela
dit il faut toujours la Serbie la
Croatie c'est ce sont des des plaies qui
se réveillent constamment il faut faut
veiller il faut il faut veiller à ça il
faut faire attention j'étais cette
semaine
la commission des affaires étrangères
sûrement rapport et on a soumis à la
séance publique qu'il a qu'il a approuvé
les protocoles de ratification des de
l'élargissement de l'OTAN à la Suède et
à la Finlande et je crois que ça a
apporté une grande sécurité parce que ça
a apporté la clarté ce qui est embêtant
c'est tous ces pays incertains
Ukraine en était éteint la Moldavie la
Géorgie qui sont fondamentalement
attirés par le modèle politique
économique et social de l'Ouest mais qui
n'ont pas les garanties correspondantes
et ça ça crée exactement comme aliouan
c'est insécurité crée le risque en
soi-même alors il faut que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités et là je crois que
vraiment les Européens ont intérêt à
veiller avec beaucoup de soins sur sur
les Balkans et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que contrairement à ce qu'une grande
partie de l'opinion française pense il
me semble
utile nécessaire que les pays
balkaniques rentrent dans l'Union
européenne parce que sinon ça sera
vraiment un risque d'explosion tout à
fait grave
j'agis tout à fait dans ce sens avec mes
amis italiens de mon homologue italien
de la de nous avons fait pas mal de de
colocs de réunions de réflexion avec
l'ensemble des dirigeants balkaniques
parce que nous estimons que il faut
effectivement que l'Union européenne
s'affiche plus fortement dans cette
région dans cette région d'Europe et que
les Balkans occidentaux suivent le
destin des autres monsieur bourlange au
début du mois de mars sur Europe 1 en
l'occurrence vous aviez salué l'arrivée
de des réfugiés Ukrainiens il y en a 100
000 qui sont arrivés en France ce qui
est quand même un chiffre remarquable et
vous disiez il tous les accueillir très
bien parce que ce sont des gens de
grande qualité qui sont formés et dont
on pourra tirer profit et donc il y a
des tas de gens qui ont dit ah bah oui
alors ceux-là on les veut bien mais les
autres qui viennent de l'Afrique et du
Proche-Orient on en veut pas
idiot parce que c'est ce qui est idiots
j'en ai pris plein la figure et la
vérité c'est que c'est une formule que
j'avais employée antérieurement à propos
des gens de Calais parce que je disais
que des gens qui avaient franchi toutes
les mers la moitié du moule est danger
qui avait pris les risques qui arrivait
à Calais etc c'était des gens d'une
qualité alors le mot le mot pas bien
choisi c'était le mot profit mais je
mais c'était des gens d'une extrême
qualité d'une très grande qualité et
qu'on avait vraiment tout intérêt alors
je sais pas s'il faut le bon intérêt et
plus heureux que le mot profit et qu'on
avait tout intérêt à les accueillir
parce que ce serait un apport
considérable pour notre société que
n'avait dit compris depuis lors que
effectivement il y a tout un ensemble de
milieux qui disent que les réfugiés
Ukrainiens sont de des sens inférieures
aux autres et ça c'est pas vrai non plus
nous avons à faire à des gens qui sont
dans le malheur qui se battent pour leur
liberté qui nous ont rejoint et je ce
que j'ai voulu dire à ce moment-là
c'était assez clair que nous n'avions
pas à avoir peur de cette émigration
même si elle est assez massive comme
vous le comme vous 100000 selon vous
les programmes de mathématiques en
France c'est vraiment facile à côté de
ce qu'on fait en Ukraine donc ça peut
peut-être nous interpeller quelque peu
sur notre niveau de formation à
nous-mêmes monsieur bourlange vous savez
forcément que il y a un journaliste
français de libération qui s'appelle
Olivier Dubois qui est otage au Mali
depuis avril 2021
on a plus de ses nouvelles vous au poste
qui est le vôtre est-ce que vous en avez
non j'ai pas davantage de nouvelles que
vous c'est une affaire
l'évolution intérieure du Mali est quand
même une terrible une terrible déception
pour nous tous on s'est jeter dehors
nous nous sommes nous sommes mis au
service du Mali alors demande à la
demande de la Communauté des États
africains de l'Ouest à la demande des
Nations Unies nous avons fait nous
faisons un travail moi j'ai été voir nos
troupes non pas au Mali parce que on
était déjà plus en situation mais je les
ai vu au Niger et j'ai vu le dispositif
français au Sénégal et à Abidjan nous
avons des militaires qui font un travail
exceptionnel maintenant l'évolution du
Mali elle est terrible mais elle est
terrible parce que ce n'est pas du tout
une alternative à
ce que nous représentons c'est le
colonita SE
rétrack sur un petit un petit territoire
qui contrôle directement et le reste du
pays
protégé quant à lui par des milices qui
se livrent à des exactions épouvantables
et puis le reste du pays n'est plus
contrôlé et donc il y a effectivement un
développement du terrorisme qui se
rapproche du Golfe de Guinée qui est
extrêmement préoccupant et au milieu de
cette situation la situation de monsieur
Dubois est terrible merci en tout cas
d'être venu Jean-Louis borlange donc
député Modane pardonnez-moi
factuellement mais en l'occurrence ce
que j'avais vu sur une source que je
nommerai pas était parfaitement faux je
l'ai pas inventé en l'occurrence les
présidents de la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'Assemblée nationale sur
LCI ce vendredi matin je vous souhaite
un bon été monsieur